[Musique]
or à tous hop bonjour bonjour à tous
bonjour à tous
c'est monsieur drevet aujourd'hui c'est
le jour où on dévoie leur famille à
gagner les concours les cadeaux pour les
concours mais fausse pour le concours
spec là les produits sont là donc on va
se faire une petite vidéo c'est court
juste pour voir qui a gagné qui est la
grande gagnante le grand gagnant tous
ses produits il ya six produits ont tout
à gagner
on y va
[Musique]
ya pas très longtemps vous organisé un
concours pour vous faire gagner deux
smartphones de chez des fausses et
d'ailleurs je vous ai fait un petit test
de ces produits c'est le défaut c'est
cette voie là j'avais dit que je vous en
fais gagner 1 et ils sont entraînés les
2000 like nous on faisait gagner 2 bon
on n'est pas très loin des 2000 like
j'ai pas une peau de vache fait gagner
les deux à côté de ça on avait fait un
concours également pour faire gagner des
coques en partenariat avec spec qui fait
très très très jolie coque et l'idée
c'est effectivement matar dissiper et
puis un tirage au sort sa porte et a
gagné sa coque si ça voilà donc il est
petit coq là j'avais effectivement la
président hugh noir la précision lear
qui la lie à la plaine tous les côtés il
y avait là presidio grimm là et ensuite
alors très idiot ou wallet c'est
celle-là on peut mettre ce type de carte
bleue dedans alors là aussi c'était tout
bête il fallait remplir un petit
formulaire pour gagner ça et pour gagner
ça et ensuite avec un tirage au sort
j'ai fait le tirage au sort est
justement je vais vous dire qui a gagné
vous allez voir c'est super cool déjà je
tiens à vous remercier énormément vous
toutes et vous tous parce que vous avez
été super nombreux déçus tant nombreux à
participer pour gagner
dumas pour tenter votre chance pour
gagner elle sait quelles doses très très
sympathique
donc ça déjà merci grand pouce pour vous
grand coeur sur vous super alors je vais
continuer à vous gâter un vous allez
voir quand j'aurai donné les noms des
personnes qui ont gagné je vais vous
dire que dans la boîte là et ce qui va
arriver très prochainement en concours
donc on va regarder où j'ai fait un
petit tirage au sort tout bête tout bête
pour on va déjà levé pour les coques
spec alors la toute première c'est la
présider au voile est la preview molex
et celle qu'on peut mettre sa petite
carte bleue à l'intérieur la président
est honnête a été gagné par jimmy
verriest jimmy c'est pour toi
jamie qu'il est très souvent c'est
vraiment un tirage au sort c'est pas moi
qui ai choisi jamie qui est là depuis
très longtemps et qui laissent des
commentaires sur twitter qu'un petit
plateau du jimmy c'est pour toi je
t'envoie un mail et tu m'envoies toutes
les infos
modèle de smartphone complet d'ici et ça
et on fera le nécessaire pour que leur
soient rapidement ensuite la présider au
grimsel la halle avec l'anti dérapant le
joli patins là celle-là elle a été
gagnée par dorian ménagers félicitations
d'orient donc pareil à un email et puis
tu me diras quel smartphone tu as la
président de clear la transparente celle
là là celle-là elle a été gagnée par
eddy leroy félicitations et dit pareil
un mail es tu me diras tout ça est la
dernière c'est la président jean-noël à
toute simple sobre mais aussi très
efficace et très jolie up client était
gagné par le président jean noir par sa
nouvelle sa nouvelle ou samuel j'ai vu
un vais donc jeudi à sa nouvelle quête
chi tiens voilà sa nouvelle c'est pour
toi pareil un email et on reste
connectés
voilà félicitations à tous les quatre
gagnants pour ses fameuses coque de spec
ce qui dope cadeaux à gagner un expect
d'ici d'ici quelques temps donc une fois
de plus restez connectés et puis les
perdants pour tenter leur chance
probablement sur un auto portrait très
très prochainement
ou alors sur le cadeau mystère qui est
dans la boîte là que vous dévoilerai
d'ici quelques instants
alors ensuite concernant les défauts ses
sets je vous ai dit je vous ai fait un
test les produits sont sympas sont
passés du smartphone d'entrée de gamme
mais c'est très bien voilà on va pas se
mentir c'est pas le truc le plus fou fou
les plus dingo du monde ça fonctionne ça
fait un bon smartphone
et puis pour le coup surtout il est
cadeau est offert donc on repart à l'est
alors on a deux gagnants du coup voilà
hop hop on a un jeune boyard la jolan
félicitations tu vas recevoir un des
deux modèles et le deuxième c'est serge
montus sq la baule à serge j'espère à
vous deux que j'ai pas écorcher vosnon
félicitations pareil je vous envoie un
email et vous saurez vous
j'aurais voilà je dis bien votre adresse
mail en somme un petit mail vous avertit
compagnie on se fait des bisous et total
voyez un petit peu le système
donc félicitations à ces six gagnants
qui ont remporté leurs cadeaux je suis
désolé pour l'autre vous avez été
extrêmement nombreux
plusieurs centaines de participants mais
bon beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup
donc monté pas gagné néanmoins le cadeau
que je vous ferai c'est la grosse bise
tout de suite hein voilà les
félicitations bravo vous avez participé
et comme on dit plus important c'est de
participer
même si effectivement c'est quand même
mieux tomber c'est quand même mieux de
gagner son cadeau alors ensuite
rassurez-vous va y avoir d'autres
concours a régulièrement il ya plein de
choses à gagner donc on va se faire
plaisir on va se gâter on va faire des
gros cadeau et là j'ai autre chose à
vous faire gagner
alors si vous avez un suivi un petit peu
et les différentes vidéos sur la chaîne
vous êtes déjà au courant puisqu'il
s'agit de coke de smartphones mais pas
n'importe lesquels il s'agit de coqs
rhino schild alors très sympa il ya des
produits qui sont vraiment super sympa
bon jeu montré très très vif et puis il
y aura une vidéo où j'explique
récommandé gagné donc pour l'instant
vous affolez pas elles sont pas encore
en jeu donc rester jusqu'au dect
abonnez-vous parce que ça va pas tarder
là vous avez un effet un petit peu bois
passion pas trop être la lumière
vous avez un effet un petit peu carbone
très sympa ça ça va arriver aussi très
très prochainement celle là c'est là
toute blanche très joli très efficace là
vous avez la grille et là vous avez un
magnifique avec les faits doivent donc
là il ya plein de certification il ya
plein de trucs et de ces produits donc
on va en reparler très très
prochainement c'est pas le sujet du jour
le sujet s'est félicité les gagnants
donc merci à vous merci d'être là
étaient deux fois plus nombreux toujours
plus nombreux à regarder les vidéos
bravo aux gagnants
désolé pour les autres mais vous avez
tenté votre chance très très
prochainement donc on reste ensemble
d'ici là soyez ça je vous embrasse
il a plutôt qui n'attend pas
[Musique]